-Now, we all love our pets,
and every pet owner thinks
that their pet is the best.
Well, I wanted to see
if that was true,
so it's time for "Why Is
Your Pet Better Than Me?"
Here we go.
-♪ Why is your pet
better than me? ♪
♪ Better than me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, let's meet
our first pet.
Welcome. What is your name,
and where are you from?
Oh, I see somebody.
-I'm Jessica Hentoff.
I'm from St. Louis, Missouri.
-Yeah, hello!
Oh, we love St. Louis.
Jessica, thank you for joining.
And who do you have
with you there? Wow.
-This is Miss Maple.
-Oh, Miss Maple.
It is a pleasure to meet you,
Maple.
Can you tell me, Jessica,
why is your pet better than me?
-Because Miss Maple
can pack her own suitcase.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
-That's true. I really can't
pack my own suitcase, but --
She can pack her own suitcase?
Can we see it?
-Of course you can.
-Alright.
Wow.
-Maple.
-They just loosened the travel
restrictions, so this is --
-Are you ready?
-Yeah, sure.
Drum roll, maybe?
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
-Back up.
Back up.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
What?!
That is unbelievable.
Maple, great job!
Jessica, Maple, great job.
Oh, my gosh.
Maple, let us see your --
your cute little face.
Oh, fantastic job.
Jessica, thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nailed it.
Nailed it right there.
Let's meet our next pet.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hello. I'm Lynne, and I'm
from Derbyshire in England.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
Now, Lynne, you have a lot --
Seems like you have
a lot of pets there.
Who is the gang there?
-I've got 10 toy poodles
altogether.
They're all family.
Mojo, in fact,
here is a grandma.
And then I've got aunties,
uncles, daughters,
all sorts here.
This is Pixie.
-Hi, Pixie.
Yeah, Pixie is like,
"I want to do a trick, too."
But which one tonight is gonna
show off their talent?
-It's our little Mojo here
that is our trick dog.
-Oh, wow, alright.
So this is --
Mojo, this is your big,
shining moment.
Mojo all the way from England.
Mojo, why are you
better than me?
What's your trick, pal?
-Well, Mojo can play the piano
and sing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, I can't do that.
But I try.
But, alright, let's hear Mojo
and see what we have.
Whenever you're ready, Lynne.
Thank you so much.
-Okay.
Mojo, Mojo, Moj.
Come play
Play, play.
[ Piano playing ]
Come play.
Play, play.
-[ Laughs ]
That's it.
That's all you need.
Mojo, great job.
[ Piano playing ]
[ Dog barking ]
-Sing. Sing.
-Oh, my God.
Playing all the hits.
Mojo, thank you
for playing the hits.
I know people don't want
to play the hits.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Lynne, Lynne,
that was fantastic.
Thank you very, very much.
Now it's time to meet
our last pet.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hi. I'm Kelly from
Orange County, California.
-Hey, Kelly from Orange County.
Yeah, we love ya.
Kelly, who do you have there
with you?
-I have my pigs,
Norman and PigPig.
-Oh, my gosh.
And PigPig is great.
Now, I love the name PigPig.
Kelly, why is PigPig and Norman
better than me?
-Well, I believe that
they're better than you
they they can drink a beer,
non-alcoholic beer,
in 30 seconds faster than you.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
-I've never drank
a non-alcoholic beer.
[ Rim shot ]
Thank you very much.
No, the pig can chug
a non-alcoholic beer
in 30 seconds?
I'd love to see this.
-They're better than a frat boy.
-Can we get 30 seconds
on the clock?
Roots?
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
Drink, drink, drink,
drink, drink.
Whenever you're ready.
-Go for it.
-Yeah, go for it, buddy.
Yeah, they love it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, the party animals.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And what's beer
without some beer nuts?
-They are -- They are literally
party animals.
I love it so much.
A great job to all
of our talented pets.
If you have a pet you think
is better than me,
I want to see it.
Go to tonightshow.com/
whyisyourpetbetterthanme.
Submit a video of your pet.